there's a sense that the Republican
Party doesn't like different types of
individuals that kind of difference
whether it's gay people or minorities
that you know they see they want a
standard-issue American how'd it have
you how do you I would boy the
Republicans are about empowering
everyone hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and we're at the reboot
conference in San Francisco we're
talking with representative cathy
mcmorris rodgers she's one of the
keynote speakers a representative of the
fifth congressional district in Spokane
Republican Kathryn McMorris Rodgers
thanks for talking to us thanks good to
be with you why should the tech industry
I mean the reboot conferences is talking
about bringing the tech industry and
Republicans conservatives libertarians
together why should the tech industry be
receptive to the GOP because because the
GOP is the party that is about
empowering people individuals it is
about ideas promoting innovation
entrepreneurship startups new new ideas
it says I like to think that we're the
party that is about pursuing new ways
and and how do we improve people's yes
let's you know that's certainly the
rhetoric and then there's a sense that
the Republican Party is kind of old and
backward looking you know that it's
longingly looking at a golden age in the
past always so how do you get past that
kind of perception about and that's
that's where I think the Republicans is
very important that we are embracing
this new that we're embracing technology
that we're embracing the spirit of
innovation and that we're embracing what
this new approach can offer to us as
Republicans and the agenda that we have
long been promoting that is a it's
limited government and it's individual
is empowering individuals and and
promoting entrepreneurship so I guess as
as Republicans it really is up to us to
embrace what technology can offer both
in engaging people as well as public
policy here's a question for you you
know the Republican Party mean
technology one of the great things that
it does is it allows you to
individualize and personalize things in
ways that were on a mat
believe in ten or fifteen years ago
there's a sense that the Republican
Party doesn't like different types of
individuals that kind of difference
whether it's gay people or minorities
that you know they see they want a
standard-issue American how'd it have
you how do you boy
the Republicans are about empowering
everyone individuals no matter who you
are no matter your background and we we
have to reach out to people across this
country we got to make sure that that
the face of the Republican Party is one
that reflects the the diversity that we
see across this country and that and
that people see Republicans representing
every background every walk of life
where we're younger than the Democrats
well it means that we are five years on
average younger in the house we have
twenty-seven members under forty we have
Hispanics we have women and that's where
I think so often we we don't do a very
good job of maybe marketing or so
promoting that our face is a broad face
that represents every corner of this
country every background what are the
big technology issues not about
companies but in in your district what
are what are some of the technologies or
innovations that you see that are being
stifled by federal regulations
well you just see time and time again
where the federal government gets in the
way it's making it difficult to move
forward on anything what working through
a permitting process of a regulatory
process it is not promoting the new
ideas and new approaches new innovation
you know and you know everyone likes to
point right now to uber and what it what
it is offered and and that's just one
example but that's where we need to be
the party that is embracing the the the
what technology can offer in every
industry and we certainly see where it
has just revolutionized do you I mean
with something like uber Airbnb you know
do these not I mean they challenge
regulatory frameworks right we're I mean
in a way the government is no longer
even necessary because uber regulates
itself it regulates a driver it even
regulates its customers is the
Republican Party comfortable kind of
large with that and saying you know what
these are you know we don't need the
government to be regulating our business
we don't need it to be regulating our
social life well I it's a it's the
Republican Party that believes in a
limited role for the federal government
and really keeping decision-making at
the local level and and I think as much
as that the regulation that's needed
keep it local keep it that the city the
county level the state level the idea of
the federal government knowing better or
the one-size-fits-all top-down approach
Republicans believe in a bottom-up
approach
does that include things like abortion
and gay marriage I mean where where are
those two should those be decided at the
individual level at the local level
should that be outside of politics
altogether well I think you're seeing
more and more we're you know take the
whole issue related to same-sex marriage
and and I think you're you're seeing
where the Republicans are saying well
let's leave that at the state level
allow states to decide what is what's
best and the idea of these federal
government policies would be more
limited so I mean would you be
comfortable with the I mean the National
Republican Party just saying you know
what the federal government has never
really defined marriage it should just
not even be dealing with it well there's
I think there's a I think we need to
look at who is defining marriage I'm
someone that does believe in marriage as
being between a man and a woman but
there's a there's a question as to civil
unions and and what is legally needed
where the government should be involved
in making these decisions and
recognizing certain would be
uncomfortable then I mean you know
recognizing that marriage is maybe
marriage is a religious institution and
and church as individual churches should
govern that but then should the federal
government recognize civil unions
between two men or two women well that's
the debate that's going on right now
within the party Reason Foundation just
conducted a poll of national poll of
about 2400 Millennials 18 to 29 year old
voters 22% of the Millennials said that
they were either Republican or lean that
way compared to about 40% of the
older voters about 43 percent of
Millennials lean Democratic or our
Democratic versus 49 percent if the GOP
remains the part or perceived as a party
that is kind of hostile to gay rights or
marriage equality hostile to
legalization of pot hostile to the
emigrate to immigrants can it go forward
I mean will that 22% crop up or like how
how is the you how is the Republican
Party gonna grow its market share among
the Republican Party must be seen as a
party that is about empowering people
individuals and families and allowing
them to make better decisions for
themselves and the federal government
ever can and it needs to be a party that
you know this idea that we're
anti-immigrant I mean the history of
this country is one that has it's a
history of people coming from around the
world to pursue the opportunities that
this country has to offer and that's
that's what the Republican Party has to
be about we have to continue to talk
about the the opportunities that this
country has to offer are you
uncomfortable with some of the rhetoric
from I mean Steve King of Iowa for
instance is extremely and openly hostile
to Mexican immigrants I mean is that a
problem for the party we you know he
does not his his position does not
reflect the the broad view of
Republicans all across this country we
believe that we need to fix what is a
broken immigration system and that those
that want to come here for the short
term or the long term can do so now it's
also important that you know we we
secure our border and obviously what's
going on right now at the border only
screams that we we need to get in place
and build the trust with the American
people that they have some confidence
that the federal government is doing
this job and in this case it's one where
it's making sure the question the
export-import bank is coming up for
reauthorization it is by people like
Kevin McCarthy the new House Majority
Leader said he's going to vote he's
going to put it down this is a program
that gives subsidies to foreign
countries to buy American products Eric
Cantor Reid was led to reauthorization
in 2012 are you in favor of
reauthorizing the export-import bank and
do you think that that's a big issue
that Republicans need to be on one side
or the other on well I I'm someone that
I did vote two years ago for the
reauthorization of the import-export
Bank you know there were some reforms
attached to that transparency and other
reforms that this administration has
never implemented and that's it's
another example where the trust is
broken and the administration is not
doing what it is supposed to do under
the law of the land and so we're we're
working through I think there's some
questions that need to be answered and
so have you made a decision yet are you
going to vote to reauthorize the
export-import bank in in September or
well we all see what that looks like
when when it okay all right well thank
you very much I want to thank
representative cathy McMorris Rogers of
the 5th Congressional District of
Washington State for talking to Reason
TV I'm Nikolas